Researchers think babies begin developing language skills while they are in the womb.
Campbell was in law school when she was pregnant with Finn.
Plus, I was finishing my last semester of law school.
So, I guess, check back with me in 30 years and see if he's a litigator,...
...because he definitely would,...
...come alive in my Corporations classes and he always heard my professors speaking.
Professor Kathy Hirsh-Pasek directs the Infant Language Laboratory...
...at Temple University in Philadelphia.
But we think the very first processes...
...of language development are actually starting in the womb...
...because they're overhearing their mother's speech.
Researchers say that's when babies pick up the melodies of language.
They can sometimes remember some of the words that they've heard...
...and they appear to zoom in on classes of language.
They may not know French from Spanish,...
...but they know that that's in one group...
...and that the English and German is in another group.
There goes the doggy.
Another study shows that babies and children...
...who are frequently talked to have higher IQ scores and later on, do better in school.
Throw it! What did the dog say?
Child development specialist Judy Montgomery encourages parents to talk to their babies.
Parents and caregivers, the family members, are the first ones to introduce vocabulary.
And the more words the children hear, the greater their vocabulary.